musk oxen male stand five feet at the
shoulder and weigh a massive 800 pounds
aside from polar bears they are the
largest animals that roam the arctic
tundra but even they are vulnerable to
predators a pack of arctic wolves
catches the herd set
the musk oxen scrambled to form a
defensive ring the adults equipped with
long hooked horns are more than a match
for the world but it's not the adults
the wolves are at the herd panics and
runs it is a fatal mistake their lines
broken they cannot protect their young
the Wolves separate out attack though
it's as large as the alpha male wolf the
calf is still one against mental without
the help of a third the calf eventually
succumbs to attack a few days later the
wolf pack is on the hunt again their
quarry as before our musk oxen the opsin
tried to run away but this time the
adults stick close to their calf built
for the frigid arctic musk oxen will
actually overheat if they run for too
long they were all around to face off
against their pursuers the Wolves try
again to make the run but the attempts
are half-hearted at best and the oxen
stand their ground opting for easier
targets the Wolves move on weaving the
tundra free for the musk oxen to roam
again